ฮะโอเคสวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครู Arty
สวัสดีค่ะคุณนะครับนักเรียนได้แค่กลับมา
เจอกับเรา 2 เทิร์นนะครับเจอครัวลุงส่อง
ครูพี่เอ๋เอ๋ใช่ครับเราสองคนน่ะกลับมาเจอ
กันในช่องคอม friend สะโบไทยนะครับหน้า
เราไม่เจอกันเป็นประจำครับเป็นประจำทุก
วันอะไรครับทุกวันจันทร์ค่ะค่ายแล้วเรา
ไม่เปลี่ยนวันไม่เปลี่ยนครับวันจันทร์วัน
เดียวนะครับจันทร์วันเดียวกันใช่ไหมอะวัน
นี้วันจันทร์เนาะวันนี้วันจันทร์ที่เท่า
ไหร่คะค่ะวันนี้วันจันทร์ที่ 8 ครับวัน
นี้จันทร์ที่ 8 น่ะใช่ครับวันจันทร์ที่ 8
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนนี้เดือนสิงหาคมครับ
เดือนสิงหาคมใช่ปีเดือนที่ 8 หนูๆเดือน
ที่ 8 เอาวันที่ 8 เดือนที่เพื่อนที่ 8
5 ให้ครับต้องไปอ่ะเสื้อช็อปปิ้ง 5 วัน
นี้ช้อปปิ้งมีโปรโมชั่นราคาพิเศษ 5  8
ให้ครับปีพศอะไรคะพี่พ.ศ.
2565 ครับปีค.ศอะไรคะข้อ
2022 เย้เดือนที่ 8 แล้ว 9  10  11  12
5 หน้าตาโออีก 4 เดือนอีก 4 เดือนจะสิ้น
ปีได้มั้ยทำไมเร็ว
รู้สึกว่าไปเร็วตายไม่ได้ทำอะไรเลย
ยังไม่ได้ไหม
โอเคค่ะวันนี้นะคะคืออาชีพที่ก็จะคุยกับ
กู Arty หานะคะนิดนึงเป็นซีรีส์นี้ก็ยัง
คิดอย่างที่ป๊อกเวลาๆเมื่อกี้กูเห็นบอก
ว่าเวลาไปเร็วให้เธอมีอะไรโทรมาแล้วครับ
21:00 นแล้วตอนนี้ 3 ทุ่ม 15 นาที 3
ทุ่ม 15 นาทีแล้วนะครับเวลาที่ประเทศไทย
นะเวลาที่ครูเอ๋กับครัวตี้อยู่คือ 21:00
นแล้วตอนนี้ถ้าไม่เร็วมากนะคะใช่ครับ PM
หน้าไส้ครับเป็น TM
หาค่ะวันนี้เราจะคุยอะไรกันอ่าเอกกำลัง
ร้อนเลยวันนี้ก็ยังอยู่คือคลิปนี้ก็จะ
เป็นคลิปที่เกี่ยวกับการไปทำธุระมันน่าจะ
ได้รับการไปทำธุระนะทำธุระหรือว่าอ่าทำ
ธุรกิจอ่ะก็ได้แล้วก็มีธุระกับธุรกิจนะ
ค่ะใช่ครับก็เจอทุกวันจันทร์ก็จะมีคลิป
นึงไปทำธุระกอีกคลิปนึงไปทำภาษาธุรกิจก็
จะเกี่ยวกับธุรกิจนะครับเดี๋ยวเท่ห์อ่า
วันนี้ก็วันนี้ก็ครูพี่เอ๋อ่ะหาครูพี่เอก
จะไปอ่ะ 555 ถ้าเรียนไปไหนคะวันนี้อ่อ
หรืออย่างนี้กูอาจจะทำอะไรอ้าวคิดอย่าง
นี้เดี๋ยวคู๋มีแม่ screen ก่อนนะคะก็ได้
ครับ Share  screen เลยนะครับ screen
ก่อน ami อันนี้ให้ดูก่อนหน่อยครับอ่ะอัน
นี้เป็นเป็นบ้านไม่คุยอีกขโมยรูปบ้านของ
ของรุ่นพี่อ๋อบ้านหนูรุ่นพี่เป็นบ้านบ้าน
ทรงไทยนะคะได้ครับอ่ะสวยเลยมีบ้านอยู่
หลังนึง
พี่เขาทำบ้านใหม่แต่ว่าคนนี้กูเองไม่ไม่
ได้พูดถึงจะไปขอทะเบียนบ้านนะ
กำลังจะพูดว่าบ้านเนี่ยมันมีบ้าน 1 หลัง
ใช่ไหมครับมีบ้าน 1 หลังก็ระบบบ้านแต่ว่า
ถ้าครูเอ๋มีบ้าน
บ้านตรงนี้บ้านเพื่อนบ้านใกล้ๆกันก็มี
บ้านเพิ่มเข้ามาอีกใช่ไหมครับใช่มีมาก
กว่า 1 หลังคือมีหลายหลังค่ะแม่มีหลายๆ
เราเรียกว่าอะไรคะขวาตีพอมีบ้านหลายๆหลัง
เราก็เรียกว่าเป็นหมู่หมู่บ้านแล้วครับ
หมู่บ้านนะครับ
มันเป็นหมู่บ้านอาจจะออก 5 หลังก่อนเนาะ
เอา 70 บาท 20 หลังมนัสน่าจะเป็นหมู่บ้าน
คือในประเทศไทยน่ะอ้ะนอนตรงนี้นิดหนึ่งมี
บ้าน
มีหน้าครับ
มัน 1 ล้านก็เป็นบ้านพ่อมีบ้านหลายๆหลัง
อยู่ด้วยกันก็เป็น
หมู่บ้านมีบ้านหลายหลังแล้วก็มีคนเยอะ
ด้วยใช่ไหมมีคนหลายๆคนอ่ะคนมากๆแล้วก็ได้
หมู่บ้านนายแล้วก็มีหมู่บ้านที่ 1 แล้วก็
มีหมู่บ้านที่สองก็มี
อยู่ในหมู่ใช่ไหมครับนายหมู่บ้านที่ 3
อันนี้เราเรียกเป็นอะไรแล้วคะมีหลายๆหมู่
บ้านถ้าเป็นหลายหมู่บ้านก็ต้องเป็นตำบ่น
อ่ะเอกใช่สีแดง
เป็นตำบลได้ครับ
ถ้ามีสีแดงเป็นตำบลนะถ้ามีตำบลตำบล
บนหลายๆตำบลรวมกันอ่ะเราก็จะเรียกว่า
เป็นอะไรคะเรียกว่าเป็นอำเภออำเภอนะคะ
แล้วถ้ามีอำเภออำเภออำเภอหลายๆอำเภอหลาย
หลายอำเภอหลายอำเภอก็จะเป็นจังหวัดเป็น
จังหวัดๆทั้งในประเทศไทยนะมีจังหวัดทั้ง
หมดกี่จังหวัดนะคะถ้ามีหลายหลายจังหวัด
ทั้งหมดทุกจังหวัดรวมกันก็เป็น
111 ประเทศครับประเภทเส้นที่จังหวัดมี 77
จังหวัดนะคะได้ประเทศไทยณประเทศไทยมี 77
จังหวัดอะเคเทศไทยประเทศนักเรียนมีกี่
จังหวัด
คุณดีไหมคิดว่าบางประเทศอาจจะไม่ได้เรียก
ว่าจังหวัดการถ่ายเรียกตามภาษาของแต่ละ
ประเทศขณะนั้นชายวันที่อาจจะยังอเมริกา
ไม่เป็นจังหวัดก็เป็นรัฐเป็นรัตน์นามว่า
เป็นเมือง
เป็นรัฐรัฐจะใหญ่เราก็เป็นเมืองเมืองจะ
เล็กมาก
โอเคกลับมาที่หมู่บ้านกลับมาตอนนี้หมู่
บ้านของเราก่อนกลับมาที่หมู่บ้านยังลืม
ที่นี้หมู่บ้านนะคะมีหมู่บ้านก็ต้องมีหัว
หน้าหัวหน้าหมู่บ้านใช่ไหมหัวหน้าหมู่
บ้านหัวหน้าหมู่บ้านเราเรียกเรียกว่าอะไร
อ่ะผู้ใหญ่บ้างเป็นผู้ใหญ่บ้านที่คอยดูแล
เธอคนที่อยู่ในหมู่บ้านทุกๆคนใช่ไหมได้
ออกแค่นี้อันนี้เป็นหมู่บ้านนะคะนักเรียน
หมู่บ้านก็จะเป็นผู้ใหญ่บ้านถ้าเป็น
อันนี้สีแดงนี่ 15 ได้ยกเป็นตำบลใช่ไหม
ครับทำบนหัวหน้าตำบลเนี่ยเรียกว่าอะไรนะ
คะก็เป็นคนที่หัวหน้าตำบลเนี่ยเรียกว่า
กำนันคือเอกไม่มีรูปกำนันนะคะนักเรียนที่
นั่นก็กำนันก็จะช่วยดูแลผู้ใหญ่บ้านของ
หลายๆหมู่บ้านในตำบลนี้อีกทีนะผู้ใหญ่
บ้านแต่ว่ากำนันนะคะๆแล้วก็มีกำนันกำนัน
กำนันคนที่ดูแลกำนันอีกทีนึงอ่าคนนี้
เนี่ยเป็นนายอำเภออย่าเพราะว่าว่าหลายๆ
หลายๆตำบลรวมเป็นอำเภอใช่ไหมคนที่เป็นหัว
หน้าที่ดูแลอำเภอก็เรียกว่านายมีอำเภอนาย
อำเภอนายอำเภอก็จะอยู่ที่ที่อำเภอเนาะอ่า
ใช่กับเลยอยู่ที่อำเภอเมื่ออยู่ที่อำเภอ
นะคะกูเองสมมุติเป็นออฟฟิศของนายอำเภอ
แล้วกันนะคะ
หมายเหมือนไหม
ที่อำเภอนะครับอายครับที่นี้นักเรียนคะ
ที่เราจะคุยกันวันนี้ก็คือเรามาที่บ้าน
บ้านมาที่บ้านอีกแล้วถามเลยกลับมาที่บ้าน
ก่อนลบให้เหลือบ้านเดี่ยว
บ้านเดี่ยวที่บ้านนี้นะคะปกติบ้านคนเราก็
จะมีมีอาจจะมีพ่อน้องมีพ่อมีแม่ครับพ่อ
กับแม่คือผู้ชายกับผู้หญิงแต่งงานกันนะคะ
ครับแต่งงานกันหนาว port พูดพอมีลูก
มีลูกโอ้ไม่รู้ว่าทำไงถ้ากูมีลูก 3 คนเลย
เหรอพี่เอ๋ก็มีลูก 3 คนแล้วก็เลยเรียกว่า
พ่อกับแม่
โตๆนะครับลูกโตรูปก็อันนี้เป็นลูกคนโต
เป็นผู้ชาย
แต่งงาน
แต่งงานแล้วผู้หญิงน่ะของ
ท้องก็พ่อกับแม่เนี่ยก็จะเปลี่ยนเป็นปู่
กับย่าเนาะ
ชายหลวงปู่กับย่าส่วนพ่อพ่อแม่ผู้หญิงอ่ะ
ก็จะเรียกว่าอะไรคะอ้าเรียกว่าตาทำข้อของ
แม่เนี่ยพ่อของแม่เรียกตาตาแม่ของแม่แม่
ของแม่เรียกยายตายายๆทำอันนี้เป็นปู่อ้าว
ปู่ย่าตายาย
ปู่ย่าตายายก็ได้นะคะค่ะทีนี้อะพา
ภรรยาของลูกเนี่ยคลอดใช่มั้ยรอด
คอร์ดลูก
คลอดลูกมาครับนี่นะค่ะ
ปกติก็อยู่ไม่มีอะไรแต่ปลอกคอปุ๊บเราก็
ต้องทำยังไงดีอ่าทำยังไงดีต้องไปบอกหัว
หน้าหมู่บ้านก่อนครับไม่ใช่คอร์ดไม่เป็น
ไรไม่ได้เนาะข้อเสร็จแล้วก็ต้องไปบอกหัว
หน้าหมู่บ้านก็คือใครครับต้องไปบอกหัว
หน้าหมู่บ้านก็คือผู้ใหญ่บ้านครับต้องบอก
ผู้ใหญ่บ้านให้ครับนักเรียนบางคนทำไมต้อง
บอกอ่าจะได้รู้ไงครับว่าผู้ใหญ่บ้านจะได้
รู้ว่าอ้อมีคนมีคนเพิ่มเข้ามาอีก 1 คน
แล้วตอนนี้นะครับ
หาจะได้รู้กี่นัดสิ่งที่ต้องบอกเพราะว่า
อาจต้องบอกต้องบอกผู้ใหญ่บ้านแต่ถ้าเป็น
กรณีที่กรุงเทพครับกรุงเทพฯก็ไม่ต้องบอก
เนาะเอาไม่มีไม่มีผู้ใหญ่บ้าน
ได้
กรุงเทพไม่มีผู้ใหญ่บ้านไม่ต้องบอกแต่ถ้า
ต่างจังหวัดนะคะเขาก็จะเหมาะผู้ใหญ่บ้าน
เพราะว่าบางทีน่ะบางคนคลอดลูกที่บ้านกลับ
มาต่างจังหวัดก็ยังมีคนที่คลอดลูกที่บ้าน
อยู่ใช่ๆแต่ถ้าไปคลอดลูกที่โรงพยาบาล
กลับไปหาอ่าคลอดลูกที่โรงพยาบาลบางที่โรง
พยาบาลก็จะทำทั้งหมดให้ได้วิธีนะครับไป
ครับที่รักกำลังจะคุยกันเรื่องกันแจ้ง
เกิดนะคะแจ้งเกิดเส้นทักคลอดที่บ้านไม่
ถึงคลอดลูกออกมาแล้วคลอดที่บ้านเนี่ยนะคะ
เพราะที่บ้านปั๊บคนรากที่อีกทีจะต้องรู้
คือผู้ใหญ่บ้านน่าใช่ครับแล้วก็จะได้ทำ
เรื่องนะคะสำหรับ
ไปแจ้งเกิดนะคะแจ้งเกิดที่ไหนแจ้งเกิดที่
อำเภอ
อันเนี้ยมันชาญแตกขั้นตอนเนี่ยกู Arty
ครูเอ๋เนี่ยไม่เคยมีรูปขอ
น้องไม่เคยแจ้งเกิดใช่มั้ยเคยแจ้งเกิดเคย
แจ้งตาย
2 รอบนะโอเคโอเครอบเกิดยังไม่เคยอ่ะอ่า
ปาร์ตี้ฮะต้องถามผู้มีประสบการณ์ขอ
ปาร์ตี้มีรูปได้กวนพี่มีลูก 2 คนและครับ
ลูกสองคนก็ต้องไปแจ้งเกิด 2 ครั้งนั้นอ่ะ
ใช่ครับต้องแจ้งเกิด 2 ครั้งค่ะเอ๊ะควรตี
อะค่ะ
หน้าตาภาแต่งงานแล้วมีภรรยาอะไรนาคลอด
room ที่กรุงเทพฯหรือที่ต่างจังหวัดค่ะ
ค่ะข้อที่กรุงเทพฯทั้งสองคนครับค่ะเอออะ
คลอดที่กรุงเทพเนี่ยที่โรงพยาบาลที่ที่
คอดโรงพยาบาลเขาก็จะไปมีหนังสือมีเอกสาร
ให้บอกว่าเด็กคนนี้นะครับเกิดที่โรง
พยาบาลนี้เป็นลูกของครัวตี้อาจเป็นลูกของ
คารยาครวญตี้ 2 คนมีลูกออกมาแล้วเขาก็จะ
โรงพยาบาลก็จะไปบอกไปบอกที่อำเภอเป็น
เอกสารใบนี้เขาเขาไม่เขาเรียกสูติบัตรไหม
ไม่ใช่หน้าใบนี้ที่โรงพยาบาลให้มาจะยัง
ไม่ใช่สูติบัตรใบเกิดเป็นใบใบแจ้งเกิดขอ
ให้ไปแจ้งเกิด
เกิดว่าจะบอกว่าเด็กฉันอ่ะของกว่าติ๊บพูด
เขาจะบอกว่าวันวันมีเท่าไหร่อาวันที่ 1
เมษายนเคาปีพตอะไรคือวันที่เกิดนะครับวัน
ที่ลูกเกิดมาครับเขาก็จะเขียนเอาไว้วัน
ที่เท่าไหร่เดือนอะไรก็มีจะไรอ่าขาดสา
แล้วก็มีต้องมีเวลาด้วยเวลาที่เกิดด้วย
อ๋อ
เช้าๆสมมุติมหาสมุทร 8 โมงเช้าโอเค
ก็ต้องมีชื่อเป็นชื่อครัวตี้แล้วก็ซื้อ
ภรรยาครัวที่ชื่อพ่อชื่อแม่อ้าแอปปี้
แล้วก็
ภรรยาชื่อน้ำโอเคอ่าอ่าแล้วก็ชื่อลูกด้วย
ชื่อลูกไปด้วยเลย
อะพี่อะเขียนเป็นแบบนี้อ่าได้ฮะโอเค
อ๋อโอเคไม่เป็นไรนักเรียนเอกกะสนีย์ราย
ละเอียดพวกนี้ว่าเกิดอะไรขึ้นใครที่ไหน
เมื่อไหร่เขาจะออกเป็นสารนี้ให้บางทีจะมา
บ้างวันนี้วันที่ 1 ชาย 4  2011
555 โอเคครู Arty ใช่ครับแม่อ่ะคุณน้ำ
ครับผมเวลา 8:00 น 8:00 น 9:00 นลงพยาบาล
ๆได้ครับหน้ารายละเอียดพ่อแม่ต้องบอกไหม
คะว่า Arty บ้านอยู่ที่ไหนเขาจะมีมีมีราย
ละเอียดของผมอยู่แล้วที่ที่ที่อำเภอก็จะ
มีรายละเอียดว่าผมเป็นใครอยู่ที่ไหนมี
อยู่แล้วแต่ว่าของลูกอย่าเพิ่งเกิดใหม่
วันนี้ยังไม่มีต้องบอกให้ละเอียด
ชายกลับมาเป็นรูปของใครๆๆครับแล้วก็เอาใบ
นั้น
เดี๋ยวกลับ
ไปเอาใบที่โรงพยาบาลให้มาใบนี้ไปกับมี
เอกสารอย่างอื่นอีกที่ต้องใช้อ้านี่
เดี๋ยวครูเอ๋จะบอกว่าต้องใช้เอกสารอะไร
บ้างใช่มั๊ยเวลาไปแจ้งเกิดต้องใช้อะไร
บ้างครับมีทะเบียนบ้านอ่าทะเบียนบ้านแล้ว
ก็บัตรประชาชนครู Arty ใช่ครับหน้าบัตร
ประชาชนทะเบียนบ้านอะไร
อันนี้ไม่ใช่นะคะพี่ใบเมื่อกี้ที่ขวดตี
บอกใบใบแจ้งเกิดใช่ไหมครับ
พี่โรงพยาบาลเซ็นให้ใช่ครับว่าเป็นลูกของ
กูอะติ๊จริงๆๆใช่ครับไม่ใช่ลูกคนอื่นลูก
ครู Arty อะไรครับแล้วเขาก็เอาอันนี้ล่ะ
คะไปที่
ไปที่อำเภอใช้ครับ
ไปที่อำเภอก็ไปหาไม่บอกให้บอกนายอำเภออา
อ้าก็มีผู้ช่วยนะคะฮาๆไปครับไม่มีเอกสาร
ของครู Arty นี่ต้องไปเองไหมคะของครัวตี
ไม่ต้องไปเองควรพี่ก็เอาเอกสารทุกอย่าง
ทุกอย่างแล้วก็ให้เจ้าหน้าที่ของโรง
พยาบาลไปไปบอกในอำเภอให้เฟอร์บี้ไม่ต้อง
ไปเอง
ที่โรงพยาบาลจัดการให้ใช้ค่ะเขาก็จะบอก
ว่าคุณพ่อคะขอ
สำเนาบัตรประชาชน 3 สำเนาก็ขี่บัตรประชา
ชนตัวนี้
อ่าไปไปไปก๊อปปี้ไปถ่ายเอกสารเป็นสำเนา
ไม่ใช่ตัวจริงนะครับเป็นตัวจริงนะคะแล้ว
ก็ขอทะเบียนบ้านน่ะทะเบียนบ้านต้องเอาตัว
จริงครับเพราะว่าเพราะว่าในอำเภอจะพิมพ์ f
พิมพ์ชื่อของลูกชายของของลูกชายคนถ้าเกิด
ใส่ลงไปในทะเบียนบ้านนี้ห่าขอสำเนาบัตร
ประชาชนนะคะรถเซ็นรับรองด้วยนะคะ
ก็กวนที่ต้องเซ็นรับรองเนาะแล้วก็เพราะ
ของคุณแม่ด้วยนะคะคุณแม่ก็ถามแล้วก็ cm
นะคะเซ็นชื่อรับรองจากนั้นก็เอาทั้งสอง
อย่าง
ก็สำเนาทะเบียนบ้านแล้วก็เอกสารจากโรง
พยาบาล
ไปที่อำเภอได้ครับกรุงเทพก็จะได้ว่าเขตนะ
คะนักเรียนนั้นๆจังหวัดก็จะเรียกว่าอำเภอ
ครับน้ำเข้าก็ทำให้ๆครับกรุงเทพฯที่สบาย
สบายกลัวแต่คิดว่าก็น่าจะเหมือนอ่าเหมือน
กันถ้าเป็นโรงพยาบาลที่เขาทำทำการแจ้ง
เกิดให้เราก็จะสบายแล้วก็ไม่ต้องทำเองแต่
บางจังหวัดก็โรงพยาบาลก็มีถ้าคนไข้เยอะมี
คนมาเกิดเยอะเขาก็ไม่ได้ทำให้ไม่มีเวลาก็
ต้องไปทำเอง
เขาก็จะออกใบแจ้งเกิดให้นายที่ครูเอ๋นัก
เรียนทำไมคนอื่นหน้าตังงงเอ๋น่ะยังไม่เคย
แจ้งเกิดเพราะกูเองอ่ะไม่มีรูปเพราะไม่มี
ไม่ต้องไปแจ้งเกิดแล้วเปิดข้อที่สองครู
เอ๋ตัวกูเองน่ะคุณพ่อไปแจ้งเกิดเองอ๋อ
ของคู๋นะคุณแม่คุณแม่คลอดที่บ้านอ๋อครับ
คลอดแบบสมัยโบราณ
เป็นอะมีผู้หญิงนะคะมีผู้หญิงที่เก่ง
เรื่องคลอดลูกเราเรียกว่าหมอตำแยเป็นหมอ
เหมือนกันนะครับแต่ว่าเป็นหมอตำแยไม่ได้
อยู่ที่โรงพยาบาลนะอยู่ที่บ้านจะได้ทำหมอ
ไทยโบราณนั่นคือผู้หญิงคลอดลูกเยอะคอร์ส
รุปสิ่งๆครับทำเป็นเขาทำเขา Knock ทำคลอด
เป็นแล้วครับถึงจะมีหรอเสนา sena ปากเกิด
สมมตินะคะเกิดวันที่เกิดวันที่ 15
นะคุณพ่อ
เกิดวันที่ 16 ก็ต้องสมมติเกิดวันที่ 16
คุณพ่อไปแจ้งวันที่ 30 ขอ
ไปแจ้งเกิดวันที่ 30 น่าจะแจ้งช้ากว่าวัน
เกิดจริงของครูอตี้เนี่ยคะลูกวันอาทิตย์
แจ้งตอนนั้นเลยค่ะใช่ครับแจ้งวันนั้นเลย
นะฮะก็สมัยก่อนบ้านกับอำเภอจะไกลกันเหรอ
ได้ต้องเดินทางไปแล้วบังดีคุณพ่อก็ต้อง
ช่วยคุณแม่ดูแลลูกยังให้ว่างสิว่างยัง
ไปไม่ได้ค่ะอ่ะและจะแจ้งช้าเวลาจะแจ้ง
เกิดเนี่ยเขาจะมีระยะเวลานะคะก็คือ 1  1
ถึงกี่วันครับ 1 ถึง 15 วันขอต้อน 15 วัน
หน้ามีเวลาไปแจ้ง 5 วันนะคะห้ามเกินนี้นะ
คะ
ห้ามเกินนะแต่เกินได้ไหมคะ
คิดว่าก็น่าจะมีคนที่เอ่อไปแจ้งหลังจาก 15
วันน่ะบางทีมีธุระอยู่หน้ายังไปไม่ได้
จริงๆวันที่ 16 วันที่ 17 นะหรือว่า 1
เดือนไปแล้วถึงไปแจ้งนะครับแต่ว่าจะต้อง
บวช 1,000 บาทอ๋อต้องเสียเวฟ 1,000 บาทก็
คือเรียกว่าเป็นค่าปรับใช่ไหมถ้าปรับค่ะ
ข้าวคั่วตีรีบไปเลยครับไม่ยอมเสียค่าปรับ
แน่นอนมี 2 อย่างครับกู Arty อีกหนึ่งรีบ
ไปก่อน 15 วันนะคะไม่เสียค่าปรับกับ 2
อาจทั่วไปปั๊บอ่ะอ่ะลูกเกิดวันที่ 10
เท่าไหร่ดีรูปเกิดวันที่วันที่เท่าไหร่นะ
คะวันที่
1 เมษายนใช่ไหมคะขับรถลูกเกิดวันที่ 1
เมษายนแต่ว่าไปวันที่ 30 เมษายนวันนี้ 1
เดือนแล้ว 1 เดือนต้องเสียค่าปรับ
1,000 บาทใช่นะบางคนก็จะบอกว่าอ้อลูก
เกิดวันที่
25 บาทก็ไม่ถึง 1 เดือนใช่มั้ยเกี่ยว
สมัยก่อนมีแบบนี้นะคะสมัยต่อพอไม่อยากไม่
อยากเสียค่าปรับไม่อยากจ่ายค่าปรับใช่ไหม
ทำไมก่อนนะคะแต่ตอนนี้ไม่ได้มาตอนนี้ลง
องค์การจะต้องออกใหม่รับรองให้ว่าเกิดวัน
ไหนนะคะสมัยครูเอ๋เด็กๆแล้วก็บ้านอยู่
ใกล้ๆเมืองอ่ะก็อาจจะเป็นแบบนี้ขอกำลัง
เนี่ยบางคนทำไมวันเกิดจริงกับวันเกิดใน
บัตรประชาชนไม่ตรงกันไม่ตรงคันโอเคของกู
เอกก็ไม่ตรงนะผัวสิอ้าวเหรอแต่ตัวเองอยู่
ใน 15 วันนะเมื่อวานปีนั้นมีคนเกิดเยอะๆ
เพียงเกิดวันนี้เราเป็น
ๆไม่ได้เกิดวันที่ 30
เกมสิ้นเดือนพอดีนะครับเกิดที่อำเภอกับ
เกิดที่บ้านด้วยเหมือนกันนะคะๆอันนี้คือ
เรื่องการแจ้งเกิดเวลามีคนเกิดใหม่ในบ้าน
เราเราก็ต้องเป็นแจ้งที่อำเภอแดงผู้ใหญ่
บ้านและเคจะถามว่าทำไมต้องแจ้งผู้ใหญ่
บ้านนักเรียนแต่ถ้าไม่ได้เกิดที่โรง
พยาบาลใช่ไหมคะ
พยาบาลก็จะไม่มีคนที่รับรองได้ว่าเด็กคน
ค่ะเด็กที่เกิดมาเป็นลูกของเราจริงๆตาย
ใช่ครับนั้นเนี่ยถ้าผู้ใหญ่บ้านเป็นคนรับ
รองเพราะว่าผู้ใหญ่บ้านก็เป็นถือว่าเป็น
ข้าราชการนะเนาะครับนอกจากเซ็นรับรองว่า
คนนี้เป็นลูกของของมิสเตอร์
พระผู้ใหญ่บ้านจะรู้จักคนที่อยู่ในหมู่
บ้านทุกๆคนถ้าเค้าจอดรับรองได้ว่าเนี่ย
เป็นครูของคนนี้จริงๆครับ
ผู้ใหญ่บ้านก็จะเหนื่อยหน่อยนะ
คะเหนื่อยหน่อยเป็นงั้นเราก็จะต้องรู้จัก
ผู้ใหญ่บ้านครับว่าที่บ้านครูเอ๋สั่ง
จังหวัดคุณแม่ก็ๆเดี๋ยวไปหาผู้ใหญ่บ้าน
ถ้ามีอะไรก็เดี๋ยวไปหาผู้ใหญ่บ้านไม่ต้อง
ไปหาผู้ใหญ่บ้านไปอำเภอเลยอ๋อ
ต้องบอกผู้ใหญ่บ้านก่อนใช่ขับนะคะไม่ว่า
จะมีคนเกิดคนย้ายไปย้ายมาใส่ขับหมีจะมีคน
มาอยู่ที่บ้านเราเจอนานๆไม่ได้อยู่วัน 3
วันหรือไม่บอกผู้ใหญ่บ้านๆว่ามีคนมาอยู่
เพิ่มในครับผู้ใหญ่บ้านจะต้องรับรู้หลายๆ
อย่างนายหมู่บ้าน
เพราะว่าผู้ใหญ่บ้านเป็นคนดูแลดูแลหมู่
บ้านนี้นะครับก็เลยต้องบอกผู้ใหญ่บ้าน
เมื่อเวลาที่มีเรื่องสำคัญสำคัญนะครับ
อันนี้เป็นเค้กของเด็กที่เกิดในประเทศไทย
เนาะครับที่เป็นคนไทยกับคนไทยอ่ะมีแต่ผ้า
เป็นลูกครึ่งลูกครึ่งครับเป็นชาวต่างชาติ
ใช่ไหมถ้าเป็นลูกครึ่งก็คืออ่ะคุณแม่ไทย
หรือคุณพ่อไทยเออก็ต้องแจ้งเกิดเหมือนกัน
นะคะนักเรียนไอ้ต้องแจ้งเหมือนกันครับ
ต้องแจ้งเกิดเหมือนกันว่าอยู่ที่บ้านนี้
เกิดที่นี่ลูกของเราเพื่อที่จะเอาชื่อของ
เด็กน่ะเข้าไปอยู่ในทะเบียนบ้านครับเพราะ
ว่าพอเด็กโตโตขึ้นจนถึงอายุ 7 ปีหนา
7 ปีเรายังมีเวลาใช่มั้ยอ้ะมีเวลาอีก 5
นาทีครับพอถึงจิตตอนที่ 7 ปีที่ 7 ปีจ่าย
ครับ 7 ปีควรที่คิดว่าใช่นะ
ที่เรานั้นมันแล้ว
7 ปีก็ต้องทำบัตรประชาชนเออฮักคือรุ่นกู
เอ๋นะ 20  15  Night  5 ปีใจเขาอัดตีกี่
ปี 15 ปีเหมือนกันครับไกลกัน
งานตัดตอนนี้เขาเปลี่ยนแล้วครับเปลี่ยน
เป็น 7 ปี
อาจเด็กที่มีอายุครบ 7 ปีก็จะต้องไปไปทำ
บัตรอันนี้มีชื่อเต็มๆกูที่เห็นที่เขา
เขียนไว้บัตรประจำตัวประชาชนได้ค่ะอันนี้
บัตรประจำตัวประชาชนคนไทยก็เรียกสั้นๆคน
ไทยก็เรียกสั้นๆอีกบัตรประชาชนได้ที่บัตร
ประชาชน
ไม่พูดมาบ้านประจำตัวประชาชนชาวแต่ถ้าใคร
พูดก็เหมือนกันไทยเรียกมันประจำตัวประชา
ชนก็มีความหมายเหมือนกันฐานบัตรประชาชน
เหมือนกันนะครับหมายในการพูดได้ 2 อย่าง
นั้นหลีกครับมันก็มันก็น่าสับพอดีเราก็
พูดวันพฤหัสบดี
ได้ครับ 27 ปีก็ไปทำบัตรประชาชนบัตรประชา
ชนมีอายุกี่ปีนะคะบ้านโอ้โห
คนที่ไม่รู้
เปิดพี่ไม่รู้
ดีครับน่าจะ 5 ปีมันสว่านนี้ 5 ปีเองเหรอ
ครับ
ไม่แน่ใจไม่จำไม่ได้ก็มันออกบัตรสองข้าง
บัตรประชาชนรู้ว่า 25 เริ่มกี่ปีแล้วก็
หมดกี่ปีในบัตรประชาชนจะบอก
นะเราก็นี่ไงนี่ไงในตัวอย่างเนี่ยที่กู
เอแชร์เนี่ยเขาเริ่มทำ 5
2555 แล้วก็หมดอายุ
2560 ปีเลยหรอไม่ใช่
ยี่สิบ
ไม่รู้เหมือนกันเปิดตีไม่รู้ก็ลืมนัก
เรียนตัวเองก็ลืมน่าจะประมาณแค่รุ่นคู๋
เนี่ยสมัยกูอีกเด็กๆอ่ะ
ติดต่อขอ
เค้กสิบปีแล้วก็เปลี่ยนแต่อันนี้ 20 ปี
ไม่น่าจะใช่เพราะของกูเอ๋อาจารย์นานไปงาน
ไปนานเปล่าก็ต้องเล่นก่อนเนาะเพราะว่าวัน
นี้เราก็ก็รู้เรื่องเกี่ยวกับการแจ้งเกิด
นะคะการแจ้งเกิดว่าเวลามีเด็กเกิดก็ต้อง
แจ้งเกิดถ้าเกิดที่โรงพยาบาลโรงพยาบาลก็
จะทำทุกอย่างให้เราแค่มีบัตรสำเนาบัตร
ประชาชนคะกับสำเนาทะเบียน
ให้สิริก็คือเราเซ็นเซ็นชื่อๆครับมีเซ็น
ชื่อโรงพยาบาลจะทำทุกอย่างให้นะคะแต่ถ้า
โรงพยาบาลไม่ทำให้เราก็เอาทั้งหมดไปที่
อำเภอถ่ายไปทำเองได้ถุงลูกไปด้วยอ๋ออย่า
ลืมอย่างนึงถามลูกค้ามีชื่อของลูกก็ต้อง
คิดชื่อของรูปด้วยครับเพราะว่าเอ่อใน
อำเภอจะต้องเขียนชื่อของลูกใส่ลงไปใน
ทะเบียนบ้าน
ใช้เองค่ะเป็นคนไทยสมัยก่อนนะคะเขาจะไม่
คิดชื่อก่อนอ๋อ
คู๋นักเรียนอะรุ่นกูเองอ่ะพ่อแม่น่ะจะคิด
ชื่อตอนลูกข้อน่ะอ๋ออ๋อลูกคลอดก่อนถึงจะ
คิดว่าชื่อไหนจะไหมครับว่าเขามีความเชื่อ
ว่าไม่ให้คิดชื่อเอาไว้ก่อนคนโบราณนะคน
โบราณก็คลอดมาอาจ 7 วันหรือไม่ค่อยขาชื่อ
จริงๆหน้าวันที่ 1  2  3  4  5 ในยังไม่
คิดชื่อพ่อแม่เป็นคนโบราณเนาะอ่าก็เรียก
อะไรดีอ่ะเรียกชื่อเล่นก่อนชื่อเล่นเออ
ตาลสีแดงๆก็สีแดงไปก่อนวัน 7 วันก็ไปหา
พระภายใน 7 วันก็ไปหาพระนะก็ได้ชื่อแล้ว
ค่อยไปแจ้งเกิดรัชชมีอะไรอ่าถ้าเกิดไป
แจ้งเกิดวันแรกหรือวันที่สองเลยก็จะชื่อ
แดง
ว่าตัวอย่างสีแดงอยู่ใช่ไหมครับหาก็ต้อง
ไปแจ้งเกิดหลังจากได้ชื่อจริงเกาะตัวเอก
ก็เลยรอนานเพราะไปเสร็จนายอำเภอถามอ้อ
ชื่ออะไรลูกพ่อกูบอกว่า
ไม่รู้
อ้าว
ขี้ยังไม่ได้คิดเลยนายอำเภอ
ไม่เป็นไรที่นี่มีมีเด็กผู้หญิงเกิดเยอะๆ
ชื่อนี้เอาชื่อนี้แล้วกันขอ
เดียวกันเยอะต่อ
มันตูดขึ้นก็เปลี่ยนชื่อได้ไม่เป็นไรนะคะ
เปลี่ยนชื่อได้
โอเควันนี้มาแล้วนะคะๆครับเดี๋ยวคราวหน้า
แล้วกลับมาเจอกันใหม่ครับจะพากันไปทำอะไร
ที่ไหนนะครับเดี๋ยวคอยติดตามกันในช่องคอม
เปลี่ยนจะได่ไทยอาอ้าวันนี้เราทั้งสองคน
ก็ต้องลาไปก่อนนะครับสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีครับ
พี่เอ๋สวัสดีครับนักเรียนเป็นอารายย